>>Teacher: Guys, I know.
I know. Just take a
deep breath, you guys.
Give us a few minutes, okay?
Justin, could you stop please?
Okay. Ladies and gentlemen..
>>Narrator: Having trouble
managing your classroom?
Here are some of our
favorite tricks of the trade.
>>Claudia: One, two-- Alice?
>>Narrator: Claudia Hernandez abides
by a single rule to
quiet her classroom.
>>Claudia: The first thing you
want to do is not raise your voice.
Once a teacher starts raising her
voice, everything turns into chaos.
So we could use signs.
You know, you could count one through
ten, or you could use clapping,
or any other strategy as long as
you don't increase your voice.
>>Narrator: Share one of your tricks
with fellow teachers on Edutopia.